elle le sert comme un talisman elle qui
était frappée devant ses enfants tabassé
en public tient entre ses mains sont
désormais plus fidèles compagnons être
en phase sur la touche il est dans
lequel elle a fait appel la première
patrouille est la plus proche
je serai encore là lance annick et c'est
comme s'il ya quelqu'un qui est protégé
et il s'écrit paix au nom parce qu'avant
d'avoir vous sortir beaucoup j'ai calé
nuit que j'ai fréquentées auparavant jeu
par rapport aux horaires si je peux
intentions et la file ça va mais joli
comme avant béquille moderne dont le
soutien aux victimes de violences ce
téléphone grave danger est un dispositif
aux critères d'attribution très fermé il
est strictement réservé aux femmes
menacées par un compagnon qui a pourtant
fait l'objet d'une interdiction d'entrer
en contact
malgré cela dans le doubs les deux
appareils en circulation sont en
surchauffe
au point que le jura on a prêté un
protégé besançon il est même arrivé une
fois par rapport à une situation qui
nous est apparu d'une particulière
gravité bien de demander à une femme qui
bénéficiaient de cet appareil pour
laquelle il nous apparaissait qu'elle
était en moi graves dangers de lui
retirer pour l'attribuer à cette
situation encore plus préoccupante donc
effectivement il fallait arbitres et
doudou ma grande satisfaction de
disposer désormais de d'un plus grand
nombre de téléphones et de pouvoir
ma les attributs de façon plus souple et
de façon plus large en effet non
seulement le gouvernement vient de
décider d'assouplir les critères
d'attribution du téléphone mais le tgi
vient également de se voir dotée de
quatre appareils supplémentaires dont
deux financés par le conseil
départemental
c'est dans la continuité de
l'accompagnement qu'on peut faire à ces
femmes et qu'ils ont également souvent
elles ont des enfants nous qu'on est
aussi particulièrement sensible à la
violence qui sont faites souvent corps
et la corrélation bien sûr le téléphone
n'est ni un bouclier ni un gilet
pare-balles les victimes attendent
beaucoup plus que ça du grenelle et elle
sait qu elle-même peut grossir les rangs
à chaque instant